radical left-wing mob targeting our own
Tucker Carlson an angry group of
criminal anti-fat up outside his home
last night
the crowd chanting threats against him
and his family they vandalized his
property Tucker was at home at the time
but his wife was when the group started
banging on his front door she hid in the
pantry called 9-1-1 that she was about
to be a victim of a home invasion
DC police are now investigating the
incident as a hate crime
Dana there are a lot more details than
this apparently there was one protester
caught
it's mentioning a pipe bomb among other
details in the front door being broken
having known a lot of us all of us know
Tucker and Suzy who is one of the most
wonderful women to imagine you in your
mind's eye what it was like for her how
scary that might have been and and to
hide in your home and to not know what
was happening and understand that his
brother was there pretty quickly these
people are such cowards it is it's just
stressing and I know that if it was the
other way around that somebody on the on
the Left that had a talk show had this
happened to them at their house Tucker
Carlson would be the first to defend
them and to defend them strongly and
hopefully other people will I do want to
mention that Fox News the CEO Suzanne
Scott and the president J Wallace had
put out a statement saying how
reprehensible it was and that we as a
nation have become far too intolerant of
different points of view and that recent
events across our country clearly
highlight the need for a more civil
respectful and concludes inclusive
national conversation and they say also
that those of us in the media and in
politics very special obligation to all
Americans to find common ground that was
her statement today how do you put a
stop to it though well I think it was
kilmeade because his book got knocked
off by you know here's the thing you
can't tell your followers to confront
people and get in their faces I am glad
that other talk show hosts actually have
come out and said this is bad but I do
think I do think one way to tamp down
all of this is for everybody to put
politics back in the box where it
belongs we have led we are letting
people dictate where politics can go to
restaurants to entertainment movies
television the one thing is I can say
that and one and I can agree politics is
not part of your family it's not part of
this but the people in the street that
we're at Tucker's house are never gonna
listen to us because they don't have a
life their life is this
their life is antagonism so we can say
we got to tamp this down and be calm but
it's there it's gonna fall on deaf ears
I think a lot of it is rage and so
people get incited and the decide they
decide they're gonna take it in their
own hands and so even though we may be
having a legitimate argument or debate
here on Fox or any cable station I think
there are people who then get over the
over themselves you know overly excited
and then become threatening and think
it's legitimate to go to someone's house
well how illegitimate how ineffective in
fact it has the contrary effect I think
it gives people who support whatever you
don't like about what Tucker is saying
it gives them ammunition then to
redouble and to feel some moral
superiority to you as the protester and
I think it's so key that other people in
our business have rallied to Tucker's
side and remember not everybody agrees
with Tucker but here keep this in mind
Don Lemon someone was a arrest and
Arkansas man for dozens of threats
against Don Lemon Don Lemon and Tucker
Carlson couldn't be more opposite on
issues like diversity and immigration
but what do you see now they have
something in common which is common
indecency of people threatening you
because you're on television making a
statement by the way I get this I'm
telling you I don't like death threats
and I've seen them from both sides I
don't like it I don't like being trolled
I don't like being attacked my books my
writing I can't stand it but they fight
I just think this is where we have gone
as a country and this moment with Tucker
is a moment that we need to seriously
absorb and know that this is the time to
stop especially before we get into the
20/20 cycle well Hillary said the
resistance would stop being so uncivil
once they won the house I guess these
people never got that memo there's two
things going on here
one the state of activism in America
today there's no huge civil rights
struggle there's no draft there's
nothing that threatening going on in
American society the economy's humming
so the people that have that resistance
in their blood those people that are
born to march the streets
what are they marching for what are they
marching against they really don't have
anything against a talk show host think
about it
we love Tucker very talented guy he is a
talk show host on cable he is not the
leader of a mass armed resistance that's
taking away everybody's rights
so let's just put it in perspective the
other thing going on here is this when
you're surrounding someone's homes
you've lost the intellectual argument
Tucker Carlson makes pretty well thought
out intellectual arguments about
immigration about tearing down monuments
about trade political correctness and he
doesn't in a very thoughtful way the
people that disagree with him can't make
that intellectual argument so what they
do they're reduced to surrounding his
house and chanting and that is so
uncivilized in this country we don't
live in the Dark Ages where you rush the
house with a pitchfork these people
should man up stop being such infantile
they should be rested too and actually
if you disagree with someone there's
avenues and institutions in this country
where you could get hurt Dana made the
point you arrest them you charge them
and you throw them in prison period by
the way kill mate he's hosting Carlton I
know I know but don't think that was a
coincidence be clear to be clear Tucker
had a scheduled evening is he's gonna be
calling in so I've been told
excellent so you must too now